[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
i came home and my kids were dead
it was the most horrible day of my life
and what i mean more horrible as
my wife
that in front of me
anthony takes the stand in his own
defense as he stands trial for the
murder of his wife kids and the family
dog plus just three weeks after a
federal conviction three ex-minnesota
police officers are offered a plea deal
in their state case and a nationwide
search for a missing mother turns out to
be a hoax the latest in the sherry
papini case but first gripping witness
testimony presented in the case of
johnny depp versus amber heard what she
did and what happened
for so many people to get
affected from this
it's
it's insane
we're live in virginia with the latest
in the defamation lawsuit long crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer johnny
depp's sister and a long time friend
take the stand in the defamation trial
between the actor and his ex-wife amber
hurd law and crime's angelina levy has
been in the courtroom and joins us with
an update on the testimony antoinette
brian christie dembrowski is johnny
depp's older sister she also worked for
him she told the jurors about the abuse
that she johnny depp and their father
suffered growing up
at the hands of their mother now
dombrowski said their mother physically
and verbally abused them when they were
kids even calling johnny depp one eye
when he had to wear an eye patch for a
lazy eye depp's lawyers say that abuse
taught johnny depp how to isolate and
take it while being abused something
they say happened when heard abused him
years later and heard we should mention
denies abusing depp but dembrowski was
asked about what she witnessed between
the couple what their relationship was
like as far as she could see
johnny told amber that uh
i had just had a meeting with dior and
that you know they were interested
in
him
um
her
her reaction
to that was
she was in disbelief and sort of
disgust um because she said
dior why why would your want to do
business with you
they're about class and they're about
style
and you don't have style
you know so it was a
the insulting kind of taking away that
one moment
you know that insult is
there
what
if anything
did you hear
ms heard say about mr duff's physical
appearance
she called him an old fat man
now on cross-examination amber heard's
attorneys confronted dembrowski
with text messages that she had sent to
johnny depp back in 2014 in which she
said stop drinking stop coke stop the
pills on and then on wednesday morning
depp's attorneys called johnny depp's
friend isaac baruch he was a hit with
the gallery making everyone laugh baruch
said he's known johnny depp since 1980
and johnny depp basically financially
supports him
and his artwork so he can work as an
artist he said that he basically fell in
love with amber heard the same way
johnny depp did but he said the two of
them have not spoken since june of 2016.
that was after amber heard filed for
divorce
his family has been completely wrecked
by all of this stuff and it's not fair
it's not right what
what she did and what happened for so
many people to get
affected
from this
it's
it's insane you don't know
whether mr depp has committed domestic
violence of amber heard do you
i nev i never witnessed
i never saw or witnessed
whatever type of claim
that is that is being said but you have
seen mr depp
use drugs as well as drink and be drunk
correct
oh yeah
now baruch's testimony was important for
johnny depp because he said that he saw
amber heard each day from may 21st 2016
through may 27th of 2016 and those dates
are important because may 21st is the
day
that depp's attorneys say he went to the
apartment where he had not been staying
with amber heard and told her basically
that he wanted a divorce and that it was
over and that he was going to europe to
tour with his band in those six days
baruch said he did not see any marks on
amber heard's face and he did not
believe that she was wearing makeup
however on may 27 of 2016 he said that
she showed up at the courthouse to
request a domestic violence restraining
order and he says suddenly had a mark on
her face when johnny depp would have
been out of the country so that was an
important point that johnny depp's
attorneys tried to make amber heard's
attorneys basically say she has a lot of
skill with makeup and was wearing makeup
to cover up any bruising or injuries
brian
thanks aunt jeanette joining us today is
legal analyst dina dahl and co-host
terry austin dina what do you think the
jury got from dep's sister explaining
how he reacts to abuse and was it all
convincing
well what deb's sister said is important
that he grew up with the
his mother abusing the father and that
he kind of saw his father take it and
she believed that that's what he did in
his own adult life i mean perhaps we
will see an expert witness kind of tie
that testimony even better how that
might have affected the young johnny
depp
both as a child and as an interaction
with a future relationship especially in
a situation that's here which he is
claiming that he was the abused and not
the abuser yeah now terry isaac baruch
seems to have stolen the hearts of some
i won't say who
but is it helping to make out dep's case
in any way shape or form
brian you are 100 correct he stole my
heart first of all he's honest he's kind
he's funny and he is being a good joker
in the courtroom everyone is believing
what he's saying he's definitely helping
johnny's case i think that he's painted
johnny as being very generous as caring
as kind as giving and he really
confirmed that he did not see donnie
lift the finger against anyone and
certainly not against amber and he
confirmed like antoinette said he
confirmed that there was no mark on her
face after this violent incident so i
think he's really doing well for the
prosecution yeah andreanet uh let's go
back to depth drug abuse and some foul
language that he used in court how's
that coming into the case
well the drug abuse is interesting
because
the attorneys for amber heard are
basically saying this guy was out of
control a drug addict an alcoholic he
couldn't control himself and they tried
to act like you know dombrowski was
reluctant to talk about that there were
also some texts that came out that
showed that johnny depp months after
amber heard filed for divorce referred
to her in some pretty vulgar language to
isaac baruch so that was discussed in
court today as well all right thank you
for the great reporting as always
anjanet still ahead on law and crime
daily the defendant takes the stand in
the quadruple murder trial but first a
california wife and mother admits her
2016 abduction was a hoax
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily an
update out of new york city where the
nypd takes a suspect into custody who
they believe is responsible for a subway
shooting in brooklyn law and crime daily
co-host terry austin joins us now with
the latest
brian officials announced wednesday
afternoon they found frank james after a
city-wide manhunt authorities say the
62-year-old fired approximately 33
gunshots inside an in-line subway car at
the 36th street and 4th avenue subway
station during the morning commute
tuesday they say the gunfire sent more
than a dozen people to the hospital so
none of the injuries is believed to be
life-threatening police say a gun found
at the scene was traced back to james
investigators are scouring social media
and any additional information including
a youtube channel by someone with
james's name that mentions homelessness
new york and the city's mayor eric adams
the channel has been taken down youtube
says it violated its community
guidelines new york police department
officials announced in a press
conference wednesday afternoon about his
arrest
officers in response to a crime stoppers
tip stopped mr james at 1 42 p.m at the
corner of saint mark's place and first
avenue in manhattan
he was taken into custody without
incident and has been transported to an
nypd facility i want to commend all of
the investigators and analysts who took
part in this all hands on deck
investigation
literally hundreds of nypd detectives
worked doggedly during the last 30 hours
to bring this together we hope this
arrests bring some solace to the victims
and the people of the city of new york
right now authorities say they are
working to determine a motive behind the
shooting brian
switching coasts now to california where
a woman admits her 2016 abduction that
set off a nationwide search was all
staged this week 39 year old sherry
papini reached a plea deal in federal
court on two charges mail fraud and
lying to an officer the charges date
back to november 2016 when papini
allegedly went missing 22 days later she
was found on an interstate about 150
miles south of where she was reported
missing papini claimed two hispanic
women in a dark suv abducted and
tortured her but her ex-boyfriend told
investigators papini actually stayed
with him during the time she was missing
and that she inflicted injuries
including branding to herself popini was
married with two children at the time
according to court documents mapini will
pay more than 300 000 in restitution to
the agencies involved in the search for
her while prosecutors say they will
recommend reduced sentences the charges
could carry a sentence of up to 25 years
behind bars
no reduction in charges but likely won
in her jail sentence what do you think
it will be and why
well for one thing she will probably get
a reduction in her jail sentence because
she has accepted responsibility
she apologized and also she saved the
county the cost of
you know putting it through trial she
already cost them so much with this
manhunt that was unnecessary so we'll
probably see something less than the 25
years that she could receive
now terry legally speaking what's next
for papini how are lawyers gonna try to
get the lowest possible sentence maybe
even try to get probation i don't know
uh and do you think that this
restitution concept will be a common
penalty for hoaxes like this after the
smallett case
i do i think the samoa case has really
set an example listen this is an
obnoxious crime they did a nationwide
search and they used valuable resources
no question about it there's a fact no
one was injured but her but still this
is a very serious crime so i do think
that her attorneys are going to be
arguing to lower the amount and they're
going to say no one was hurt they're
going to say that she has had no prior
convictions you know she's done probably
community service and that we should go
light on her as far as that jail time so
that's what they're going to try to do
that'll be their next argument but
listen i do think that she should pay
lots of restitution and get some jail
time to set an example it's going to be
interesting to see what arguments they
put forward to get the least amount of
jail time and as you said maybe even
reduce the restitution thank you both
coming up on law and crime daily just
off the heels of a federal trial a state
case will soon begin for three
ex-officers charged in the death of
george floyd plus the tote family
murders we take you inside the courtroom
as defendant anthony tote takes the
stand
[Music]
welcome back 3x minnesota police
officers reject a plea deal as they face
charges connected to the death of george
floyd as long crime daily has reported
two tao thomas slain and j alexander
king were convicted on federal charges
in floyd's death earlier this year on
wednesday the ex-officers rejected a
plea deal from state prosecutors as all
three face a separate state trial in
relation to floyd's death tao lane and
king are all set to stand trial in june
on charges of aiding and abetting all
three have pled not guilty the minnesota
attorney general's office says the
officers were offered a plea deal in the
state case last month but would not
reveal the details of that plea deal
right now all three defendants remain
free on bail they haven't been sentenced
in the federal case yet
dina i'm kind of curious here what's the
strategy because chauvin's guilty state
and federal cases and now these three
are guilty on federal charges wouldn't
it make sense just to wrap it all up
together with a plea in the state like
why go forward
i think part of what we're seeing here
is that they haven't yet been sentenced
in the federal case so they don't know
how much time they will be in you know
behind bars regardless if they knew that
then i think they would have probably
evaluated the state plea deal maybe a
little bit differently but not knowing
they might have a lighter sentence than
what the state in the federal case and
what the state is offering them and i
think because of that i'm sure that went
into the fact that and also the plea
deal we don't know the terms of it may
not have been very good for them they
might have just wanted to take their
chances in court yeah it's all a numbers
game i know sometimes we call it a a
free trial because they're already
serving much worse time in a different
case so maybe just roll the dice terry
how do the federal charges differ uh
from the state charges for towel lane
and king and do you see a path to an
acquittal for either of them
well maybe i think the federal charges
that was all constitutional deprivation
of his constitutional rights so all
three were charged and convicted with
willfully deprived employed of his
medical needs and also
how and king were charged and convicted
of not helping to stop shogun from
murdering george floyd so the contrast
here for the state is they've all been
charged now with aiding and abetting
murder and manslaughter so what the
prosecution has to show there obviously
is that they assisted in the murder and
the manslaughter and that they knew that
he was being killed and that was the
intent of derek hovind so we'll see what
happens i think they have a
slight slight chance of prevailing here
yeah king and lane i think a little bit
more difficult but like i've said two
tao i think has the strongest argument
when it comes to aiding and abetting i i
don't imagine why he hasn't pointed the
fingers at the others but we'll see how
the state case progresses of course law
and crime daily will have the coverage
for you when we come back a father
accused of killing his family takes the
stand anthony toad testifies in his own
defense after his wife kids and the
family dog are all found dead in his
florida home
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily both
sides rest their case but not before the
defense calls its first and only witness
the defendant to testify in his own
defense in the florida murder trial of
anthony tote tote is facing four murder
charges in the deaths of his wife megan
his three children alexander tyler and
zoe an animal cruelty charge for
allegedly killing the family dog breezy
in december of 2019. toad is accused of
drugging his family with benadryl before
stabbing and suffocating them
prosecutors say tote lived alongside
their bodies for weeks after their
deaths on tuesday jurors were shown the
interview please conducted with tone
this was days after the bodies were
discovered when federal agents came to
arrest tote on unrelated fraud charges
in connection with his physical therapy
business in connecticut in the interview
tote confessed to the killing to killing
his wife and children on wednesday told
jurors his wife had turned on to an
eastern religion
for holistic treatment for ongoing
health problems and that it was her who
killed the kids and herself
there was some discussion about a
suicide note
were you aware of any suicide now
when i came back to the house that day
she showed it to me yes
what was her demeanor or attitude at
that time
she was trying to explain to me what she
did
was trying to
make me understand
the whole
aspect of it
was she was trying to present this as
fact
and
her
i don't believe that i can't believe i
called her some names which i never
called her before in my life
the whole demeanor of it was
this is what i've been told through my
meditations this is what i believe this
is what as she referred to as the light
has provided for her i don't know what
could have prevented it i have no idea
and that's the biggest thing that
affects me is the fact that
i didn't even see this coming
they say you know blindsided this is a
blind side by like a mack truck with
filled with dynamite
did you kill your family
no
on the next episode of law and crime
daily hear the prosecution's questioning
of the defendant on cross-examination
dean at the end of the day toad is the
only one alive to tell the story was he
believable how do you hold up uh in his
testimony that we're seeing
he actually i thought held up
surprisingly well both on the direct and
the cross and
but he has a huge mountain to overcome
because he did confess all this to the
police they do have it on video
but for somebody who who
has confessed the way he was answering
the questions i was surprised how well
he did but i don't think it's going to
be enough to acquit him on this yeah i i
don't know maybe he's going to say that
i didn't want to
damage my wife's reputation i wanted to
take the fall for her i don't know but
it's going to be like i said a huge hill
to climb uh terry with the defense
resting next or closing so what's the
weakest argument the prosecution has
that the defense is likely to jump on
you know i don't think the prosecution
has many weak arguments at all i think
most of their arguments are very strong
look the defense is going to try to say
that this was megan's idea that she was
ill she had lyme disease she had
hepatitis she was depressed there were a
slew of illnesses that you know tote
claimed on the stand and that it was
really her idea he didn't know he came
home and to his surprise the children
were dead
but i think that at the end of the day
the jury is going to say look
you could not have been innocent in all
of this she was there and alive you were
talking to her and i think the
prosecution basically is going to win
over the jury because who is going to
stab themselves so i don't think the
defense really has much to say at all i
think the best thing they did though was
to put him on the stand because before
that i think the jury could totally
speculate at least
the defense gave him some argument yeah
it's going to give maybe maybe the jury
some pause as they deliberate in this
case well thank you terry thank you dina
and thank you for joining us here at law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you